ever tell you there was a place called
fire and ice I think in New York City
where my girlfriend at the time that I
was dating sort of this stripper and she
was all hot and she took me down there
and it was kind of a swinger club and
also I look around and there are dudes
jerking off look when these guys are
sitting there's one girl getting whipped
and another girl goes this guy was would
you spit in my face please man my
girlfriend saw my god Jesus Christ so
long story short there's a dude with a
giant dong african-american fella very
muscular with his white sweats down
around his mid thigh and he's just shank
and shiny shankha and I do not rolling a
dude behind us cuz this girl's getting
spanked and he's watching and a dude is
sitting down and the circle goes you
[ __ ] hit me with that you hit me with
that bro I'm gonna punch you in the face
hit him with it like he busts or not
because you hit me with that I'm gonna
and then the guy goes I'm [ __ ] just
stand-in there man relax I didn't do
[ __ ] hazard yeah and the guy who's
jacking off with a beat the [ __ ] out
everybody in the review is huge and this
guy's like yeah well just [ __ ] it I
warned you he goes don't [ __ ]
threaten me with that and they're having
an argument while he's struggling debts
oh [ __ ] that's the most alpha male move
ever what's up bro with a dick and by
the way it was so big it curved to the
right you could [ __ ] around a corner
it's weird that you talk [ __ ] like I
would have been like wall jacket I would
say anything yeah get out of the way
no I just wouldn't say anything wow this
got work to do that was my size and way
too aggressive and would have gotten
stomped by this essentially we roll out
by NFL linebacker
we got choked up when it's cooked yeah
well I mean his dick that was fat every
bit the size of my [ __ ] I remember
just marveling at it you know mate and
were you drunk enough I'm a stayer
absolutely not I was just one around
like Where's Waldo it was I know I know
not only that but I met she knew
somebody I shook his hand and then I saw
him jerking off later and I looked at
her I go I wanna have sex with this girl
so I go let's get out of here and go
have sex which we did I got the [ __ ] out
well if she's into that yes.well thing
sex yeah she's like oh these are my
friends she got stopped off and dropped
some electrolytes off to the boys
you're definitely [ __ ] it yeah and
then she kept telling me that she was
having orgasm after orgasm but I didn't
believe her well I was doing it I was
like you know it did be and also this is
not an accomplishment I'm just having
sex with you don't tell me that I'm any
different you know I mean like what am i
I'm just moving you know you don't don't
flatter me busting nuts bro yeah
and the black guy was with us obviously
and he brought media and then he would
you I I thought what Rose namajunas
couldn't have looked better
I mean she yes she got a net crush I
hate seeing him I hate seeing someone
lose that way I mean you may have a
different take on it but I mean I felt
like Rose was so much better and now
classing nothing taken away from
what's-her-name Oh Josh yeah but um she
just looked so incredible better and
she's ever looked completely winning
running a clinic on her and then she got
thrown her head which is fighting but
well she new throat she didn't spike on
her head no she just got knocked out I
just hate seeing that
I'd rather what makes it so you saw me
just work right though yeah you said a
long time ago that Rose was just a
phenomenal athlete oh yeah
way back when yeah she's a little beast
yeah as good as it gets
I'll be if if if Kelvin verse style
Benner did 70,000 out imagine this does
around 20 or 30,000 buys that is the
strangest thing I could sell you
[ __ ] in a cup for $19.99 to get
30,000 buys yep yep maybe then we're
gonna do that she has a mother who is
she's a terrible person and when she's
he sent her flowers but because he
wasn't there and hadn't been calling her
as often mm-hmm he calls her up and she
goes you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm
not talking to you and I hate my flowers
and I threw them away and he hung off
yeah so he goes so he has his wife call
her and say well he doesn't appreciate
me he never has and why do I care and
they also send me these terrible flowers
and he's like I know but the flowers in
her town I'll tell you where the tenons
that are their 1-800 flowers socks she
goes that's his excuse he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and he never comes to visit now
he's he's his mom basically you know you
could see what he's I go what did you do
he goes oh I'm flying out
to see her next weekend oh really ugly
it's one of those crazy relationships
easy because I wouldn't be Who I am
without that terrible woman like she she
was such a [ __ ] that in a way I
had to compensate this reason a super
successful he's gonna go out there oh
he'll go out there with this one really
oh yeah tyrant oh well she's a tyrant um
well yeah I mean no one does anything
too crazy on Mother's Day yeah well my
my mother's so low maintenance he has a
mother where he oh he owes high do mom
terrible and every time people like that
who will just things they need you to
dote on them cuz they're I just don't
engage with it no I just saw better even
if your mom I'm out yeah I mean kiss
your mom didn't you know my mother's
super-low me yeah it's pretty easy she
was she's 78 though and she said I want
to see you because I went to three
funerals this week move and I'm feeling
very mortal it was your mom came from
Utah yeah she'll say of course I was
very mortal yeah that's yeah 78 my dad
is gonna be 79 that's when [ __ ] starts
my last corporate gig some I don't think
I can do them anymore because they the
rules and the the protocol that you have
to observe like and when you work for
Google you were there is a there is a
puritanical yeah I haven't work for
Google so I don't want to say this
bigger but a lot of offices it seems
there's this puritanical way of speaking
and yeah behaving I just couldn't I
wouldn't even know at this point it's
probably gotten so out of hand you know
like you I the other thing I know is
form its from [ __ ] school when I was
in school yeah but I'm sure it's gotten
way worse and when I was in school and
hug anymore like I so I think my network
or any and you're not read the Herve so
you like to creepy place no I just like
to hug without pants but you you can't
like there are certain things like humor
you have to be really careful yeah we
get I'd be fired in me yeah I know and
it's it's it's weird too because it's
like it's definitely like a problem with
like fringe groups like because here's
the deal that's when I when I do I did a
show I get in Connecticut a college show
and it yeah when uh a month ago okay and
I and the show was great
I they warn you about anything or no
otherwise went to the show and so I did
the show it was great applause breaks
everyone's happy this and that and then
one person writes a blog about the show
and and they said I was funny it wasn't
like bashing me but they were like this
one part was just to this and that and
it was offensive and it's just like well
that because that's called virtue signal
right so this is a culture where if you
can find anything racist or anything
homophobic you're a hero if I'm like
yeah you you're a hero you get brownie
peer so it doesn't matter what your
intentional no matter that you're not a
racist right but if they can just find
something and it was like she had to
find something yeah that was that was
wrong with it yeah and it is a fringe it
is a frigid because my point and that's
how you prove it is that the show was
great everyone was laughing everyone was
up giving me applause breaks and then
the one person writes the thing yes and
then anyone who hasn't been at the show
they read that that's right
so it's like that's right but I do think
that people are aware like at the end of
the day you're still selling out yeah
yeah I can't go to Chris Lea because
this blog but it is unfortunate because
one blog can cause you do have to answer
to it sometimes sometimes yeah and I
just think it sucks and I think that the
press is so irresponsible because I'll
pick up on those little yeah it's a
weird aren't even true and you know a
lot of this stuff is I don't even know
who's writing it I'm not I don't even
trust that it's a human being sometimes
it's like it's BOTS yeah yeah it's it's
a weird thing because it's not it's
definitely not it's definitely not the
majority yeah like well you know Sam
Harris on his podcast had this woman who
worked for homeland security or
something and she was a computer
engineer and she started finding that
there were people she found that they
were staging rallies appro Texas rally
and then a pro Islam rally or a pro you
know immigration rally and a pro you
know whatever and they were being staged
across the street from each other and
she was like who's doing this and she
found out it was Russia
it was literally Russian it dude it's
incredible Robel had her on the podcast
Russia is very instrumental in they have
a propaganda machine for in trying to so
social discord in this country it's
[ __ ] crazy
so a lot of times you have to be really
suspicious of a lot of [ __ ] weird
their vaccine videos on YouTube made by
Russian quote-unquote Patriots as Putin
calls but so just to make us seem
confused yeah yeah and it does cause
some issues I suppose yeah it's so weird
like if it like if I if if I was in
Russia and somebody and I was in the
government and somebody was like we got
to do this we've got to make American
confused by making YouTube videos about
vent about vaccinations or anti vaction
I would be like what will let's spend
our time doing other stuff you know what
I mean and I wouldn't even think I
simply I would be like this isn't gonna
work close work yeah which is why I'm
not in the Russian government right a
lot of them are kind of loosely paid by
the government you know it's weird yeah
so they haven't even think of myself
doing or being in the Bryan Callen
biopic you know biopic but yeah don't
say biopic right because that's [ __ ]
annoying as [ __ ] but you know what I
mean right
that's awesome if they made a biopic of
you who would play you I mean you'd have
to have somebody Moranis right what did
you say no I'm asking you if you saw
Honey I Shrunk the Kids you've seen that
right Rick Moran you think Rick Moranis
would play me
well him up at his age now right he's
retired now not that that it's young
right this one there you go I mean well
your little yeah you got it there couple
things your little round or you gotta
take it back now if he was gonna do your
biopic take it back no idea I don't want
to you know want to [ __ ] spindly legs
do we forget how spindly my legs are did
you forget
do it okay can't keep I'm right just out
of reach right ah Rick Moranis would
play you did on your biopic see that's
how you get out of a fight you exhaust
the guy I'm spindle II hood like like
didn't work so yes so that's who would
play you in it's fine I think it's good
yeah
thanks man no problem let's do some
current events I'm already bored well
it's been 45 minutes
has it don't don't do that
alright is that is that a sound effect
for my shows for what are you going
tomorrow I go in tomorrow to Orlando
Orlando improv you guys get your ticket
well if you're my fan I find a mountain
fan of mine oh you looks more like Kalin
there in the bottom no no in the middle
getting depressed go go a little to the
right all right - right the second one
of the left I feel like he's my brother
who dare you go we didn't do the sports
who goes my brother was the athlete
that's what he says my brother was the
athlete so uh ya know Orlando and if
you're friend of mine go to fly to
Edmonton instead and fly to Victoria BC
instead none of that's where I'm going
you get to get across where are you
gonna be Edmonton it's a gift